A jogger and a walker set out
at 9:00 AM from the same
point, headed in the
same direction.
The average speed of the jogger
is 1 mile per hour
slower than twice the
speed of the walker.
So that's going to be an
equation right there.
The average speed of the jogger
is 1 mile per hour
slower than twice the
speed of the walker.
And then they say, in 2 hours,
the jogger is 3 miles ahead of
the walker.
That's going to be
another equation.
In 2 hours, the jogger is 3
miles ahead of the walker.
Find the rate of the jogger.
So let's write down that first
statement in equation form.
The average speed of the jogger,
let's call that the
speed of the jogger.
That's the average speed of the
jogger is 1 mile per hour
slower than twice the
speed of the walker.
So that's equal to 2 times
the speed of the
walker, minus 1, right?
It's 1 mile per hour slower
than twice the
speed of the walker.
So that's that first
statement.
And then they say, in 2 hours,
the jogger is 3 miles ahead of
the walker.
So if we go 2 hours
into the future.
So in 2 hours, the second
statement is the jogger is 3
miles ahead of the walker.
So we could say that the
distance that the jogger has
traveled, so the distance of
the jogger, is 3 miles more
than the distance
of the walker.
It is equal to the distance
of the walker plus 3.
That's all I'm saying.
This is how far the
jogger's traveled.
He's traveled 3 miles more
than the walker.
Now right now I have two
equations with four unknowns.
That's not cool.
But they've given us
some information.
They said this has happened
after 2 hours.
So we can express the distances
they've traveled in
terms of the speed
they traveled at.
Just as a bit of a review,
distance is equal to rate
times time.
In this situation,
the time is 2.
The rate is the speed
of each person.
So we can figure out
the distance.
So if you want to know the
distance that the jogger
traveled, that's just going to
be 2 hours times the speed of
the jogger.
So it's just going to
be 2 times the speed
of the jogger, right?
Distance is equal to
rate times time,
or time times rate.
Either way.
What's the distance
of the walker?
Well, it's going to be 2
hours times the speed
of the walker, right?
Distance is equal to
rate times time.
So now we can rewrite this
equation in terms of the
speeds of the jogger
and the walker.
So this equation right here.
We can rewrite it as, instead of
writing the distance of the
jogger, we could write 2 times
the speed of the jogger--
that's that right there-- is
equal to-- instead of writing
the distance of the walker, we
could write 2 times the speed
of the walker, make sure that's
a subscript-- speed of
the walker plus 3.
Now we have two equations and
two unknowns, and it looks
pretty tempting to eliminate
one of the variables.
In particular, we have a 2 times
the speed of the walker,
we have a 2 times the speed
of the walker here.
What we can do is we can
multiply this second equation
by negative 1 and then
add the 2's.
Then these guys will
cancel out.
So let's do that.
Actually let's do it
even a better way.
Let's multiply the top equation
by negative 1 and
then add them.
So let's multiply the top
equation by negative 1.
This becomes a negative times
the speed of the jogger.
This becomes a negative 2 times
the speed of the walker.
Negative 1 times negative 1
times negative 1 is plus 1.
And now if we add these
two equations.
These two guys are going
to cancel out.
And what do we get?
We get 2 times the speed of the
jogger minus the speed of
the jogger.
Well that's just going
to be the speed
of the jogger, right?
2 of something minus
1 of something is
just 1 of that thing.
These two guys cancel out.
That was the whole point behind
multiplying the top
equation by negative 1.
Then you have 1 plus 3, so the
speed of the jogger is 4.
And we're done.
That's all they want
us to find.
Find the rate of the jogger.
And we just figured it out.
If we also wanted to figure out
the rate of the walker, we
could substitute back into this
top equation right here,
or the original version of it,
which was the speed of the
jogger is equal to 2 times the
speed of the walker minus 1.
We know the speed of the jogger
is 4, so you get 4 is
equal to 2 times the speed
of the walker minus 1.
Add 1 to both sides, you get 5
is equal to 2 times the speed
of the walker.
Divide both sides by 2, and
you get the speed of the
walker is 2-1/2 miles
per hour.
But we didn't even
have to do that.
This was the answer that the
problem was looking for.